Okay, welcome everybody to another Zoom call. We're going to address some questions that you had,
particularly in cancer screening tests. So, cancer screening tests are defined in two ways.
Some people that don't know they have cancer might do a screening test to give them an indication
that maybe they need to go deeper with testing to find out if they have cancer. But also,
cancer screening tests are defined as people that have cancer to give them an indication where
they are in that either progression or regression of that cancer. Am I getting better or am I not
getting better? Is my therapy working or not working? Do I need to tweak things or not? So, let's jump
into this. So, first of all, my cardinal rule, if you've been with me for any length of time,
my cardinal rule for testing that now is just to teach other doctors, is use invasive tests only if
it's going to change the way you treat the patient. And by that, let's define what I mean by that.
So, what invasive test is a test that can possibly cause damage to a patient, possibly. So,
like a PET scan, would be an invasive test because you're drinking a glucose supplement or a glucose
drink and then you're using radiation. So, radiation can be damaging to the patient. MRI can be
damaging to the patient if you're the MRI itself. High magnetic force could affect your
your acupuncture system, but more importantly, it's typically the die. The contrast die that's used
the gadolinium that can be damaging to a person, especially if you have a sensitivity to that, it can
totally ruin your life. Or a CT scan. So, at CT scan and a PET scan, you think, oh, it's just one
CT scan. Well, one CT scan is equivalent to about 50 chest X-rays in the rad dose of radiation that
you're being exposed to. So, that's a lot of radiation. So, should I just do a CT scan just for curiosity?
Well, my point to this rule is, don't do tests just for curiosity if they could bring damage to
the patient. You do a test as a doctor. You prescribe a test. You run a test if it's an invasive test,
if it's going to, you know, quite possibly change the way you treat the patient. And as a patient,
you agree to a test if it's going to change the way you're going to treat the cancer. So,
let's use an example. So, let's say I have breast cancer. And my doctor wants to do a PET scan.
Okay, well, my question to you would be then, what are you going to do with that information? Well,
my doctor wants to do a PET scan to see if there is any metastasis. Okay, well, that's great. That's
a good thing to know. If you have metastasis, are you going to change the way you treat it? So,
let's say you're doing chemotherapy with this doctor already. The doctor wants to do a PET scan to
see if there's metastasis or any increase in cancer, because he needs to know, or she needs to know
whether we need to change the course of treatment. We need the chemotherapy that we're using. We need to
change it, you know, to plant them chemotherapy or whatever, changing the drug because the cancer
is not responding to that chemotherapy. Or if the cancer is responding to the chemotherapy,
the PET scan is improved. Well, it is changing the way we treat the patient. So, then the question,
my question to you, if you ask me that question, should I get a PET scan? My doctor wants to do a PET scan.
My question to you would be, well, if it's worse, are you going to change the way, is that going to change
the way you treat it? Are you going to do a different chemo or are you going to start chemo? And if your
answers, well, no, no, I'm not going to do chemo. Well, then why do the PET scan? So, it brings some
danger. It is an invasive test. My doctor wants me to do a CT scan on my colon cancer. Okay.
Well, why? Well, he's saying that, you know, given, you know, my increase in pain, he wants me to do
chemotherapy. Well, are you going to do chemotherapy? Well, yeah, if it's increased, I might do chemotherapy.
Well, then do the CT scan. Are you going to do chemotherapy? No, I'm not doing chemotherapy.
Well, then don't do the CT scan. If it's not going to change the way you're going to treat yourself
or agree to a treatment plan, then don't do the invasive test. Now, I understand there's some people,
maybe listening to this, that their curiosity might be driving their cancer. So, they're stressed,
they're anxiety knowing whether their cancer is getting better or getting worse where they're at,
that could be a huge factor. So, you do have to factor that piece into my cardinal rule here. But
truly, if you are a practicing doctor, you don't want to do an invasive test, unless just to satisfy
your curiosity. You do an invasive test. If it's really going to change the way you're going to treat
the patient, if it's the best thing for the patient, not just because that's the way you do it,
or not because you want to use it as a manipulative tool to get the person to do what you want them to do,
which unfortunately, I hate to say it, that is many times the reason why they do the test. So, be careful
of that. You have to control your own health care. Don't let anybody else manipulate you into something
that you shouldn't really be doing. So, when I get comments to people from patients saying,
my doctor wants me to do the CT scan, what do you think? My question is, okay, you're not doing
chemo right now. If the CT scan comes back worse, are you going to do chemo? And if they say, well,
no, no, no, no, no, I'm not going to do it. Well, then why do the CT scan? So, if their answer is,
well, yeah, I might, yeah, if it's a lot worse, I might. Okay, well, then do the CT scan.
So, understand the cardinal rule, use invasive tests, only if it's going to change the way you decide
to treat yourself. All right, so then what are the best tests for me to do to know if I'm getting
better? How do I know if I'm getting better than? Well, the best way to know you're getting better
is you compare apples to apples. If I had a CT scan that diagnosed my cancer in the first place,
getting a CT scan, again, is going to be the best way to know if what a course of treatment that
I've chosen is actually working or an MRI or a PET scan. Well, wait a second, you just said, don't do
that if it's going to, it's an invasive test if it's not going to change the way I treat, right? But
you also have to say, if you want a perfect example of whether you're getting better or not, you have
to compare apples to apples. But, but, but, but, but, but, but, these are invasive tests. So, should you
consider the next step, getting a baseline of something that's not invasive. So, I don't consider a
blood test to be an invasive test. Oh, and they're drawing blood and could you get an infection from that
blood? It's very highly unlikely. Blood tests are not invasive tests. So, get a baseline of something else.
If this is your only baseline of CT or MRI or PET scan that diagnosed your cancer in the first
place and you have nothing else to go off of, then you're, then you're bound to have to do those
things, again, to see if you're progressing in the direction that you want to progress in. So,
getting a baseline with something else is beneficial. The last several months, we've had this question
up come up about cancer, blood marker tests. We have a blog post about different blood tests for cancer
patients. Please utilize the blog and search for that. But, here's some of the cancer blood marker,
cancer marker tests. These are blood tests that are common. There's others. But, these are some
common ones. Some of these are more commonly revealed, meaning that a person with with colon cancer,
it's not uncommon for a colorectal cancer or liver cancer patient to show a positive CEA marker.
That's a specific blood test marker. These are different proteins that are found in the blood.
They have a normal range and they can be elevated with cancers. But, not every colorectal cancer patient
is going to have elevated CEA. So, you have to run these blood tests. Now, some people have had
these blood tests run and nobody ever told them about it. So, I've had patients come in and say,
oh no, I've never had blood marker tests. Well, let's look at your blood. Yeah, you have. You did
the CEA 153 and the CEA 199 and this one is elevated. Oh, well, my doctor never told me about that. Well,
that's not uncommon. So, let's take a look at your blood work and see if any of the cancer marker tests
have been run on you prior. Because, if all these are with a normal range on you, then you can't use these
as a baseline for knowing whether a certain course of care is working for you or not. Because
these have never been positive. They've never been elevated. So, you have to use a cancer marker
test that shows an elevation at some point in time to know if that's decreased or not. Now, these
all have a normal range and I don't have the memorized, but I think the CEA 125 is like zero
to 35 or something like that. And let's say it's not above normal. So, it's still with a normal
range, but it's at 25 for you. Well, even knowing that, if you had that done prior, then you could utilize
that to see if that goes down as you're trying a course of treatment. Follow me. So, you have to get a
baseline. So, even if you've started with a care program with us or you're doing chemo or whatever
you're doing and you did not run these before, you can run these now. So, you don't know if they were
elevated before if they're normal now because you didn't, you know, we don't have that as a baseline,
but we can still utilize whatever baseline you have when we run these tests. So,
just ask for these tests by your doctor. If you have a local doctor, you could ask for these tests.
We can get these tests run for you and order them, but then they don't go through your insurance. So,
we typically recommend that you ask your oncologist to run cancer marker tests. Every hospital,
every lab can do cancer marker tests. So, there's reason why, so a question we get off it is,
why did my oncologist run cancer marker tests? And here's the dirty little secret. Cancer marker tests
if they show elevated. So, let's say you have breast cancer. So, the CA-153 and the CA-199 are
commonly elevated. One are both are commonly elevated with breast cancer. So, let's say the CA-199
was elevated with breast cancer. And so, when you go to an oncologist, just understand that oncologist,
when they took you as a patient, they are just making an assumption that you're going to do what they
tell you to do. You're going to do chemo. So, if you have bucked the system and decided you're
going to not do chemo right now, you're an exception. So, a lot of oncology clinics have stopped
running tumor marker tests because they're very often elevated when a person does chemo. So,
these are enzymes that are released, protein markers that are released by growing cancers. Now,
if the cancer is dies quickly through a process called cell lysis, that will spill a lot of them.
Quite often, not always, but it quite often spills a lot of that marker and that if the person is
going through chemo therapy. So, let's say their 19-9 was elevated slightly. And then they start
chemo therapy and they get another CA-199 done maybe by their local doctor. It can show highly elevated
if the cancer is dying quickly. So, if the cancer is going through cell lysis, so there's a lot of cell
death of those cancer cells, it can spill a lot of that marker. So, it will show highly elevated. Well,
that gets the patient quite concerned. It's like, oh my gosh, I'm going through chemo. I feel like
crud that now by CA-199 just went through the rough. Oh, this is not working. And the oncologist has
to sit down and explain what I just explained to the patient. And they don't like doing that. So,
the many oncology clinics stopped running to the marker tests. So, that's why a lot of them just
don't run. That's just the honest truth. Because if you're going to go do chemo, you can quite often
have an elevated tumor marker. And it confuses the patient. They think they're getting worse.
Actually, that's a sign that it's working. So, but it's hard to explain that to a very
riled patient when they're going through chemo, they feel horrible. And my CA-199 just went through
the rough. And now I'm furious. Why is it, you know, so they stopped running these. So, you have to
ask for them quite often. So, you could ask for these. Any lab can run those. They're not super
expensive tests, but it's several hundred dollars running these tests. So, if you can get them
through your insurance, it's the best way to go. These are called cancer blood markers, cancer
markers are tumor markers. So, that's what you'd want to ask for. So, that's the other name for them.
Is a tumor marker test. So, that's what you'd want to ask for. Again, look at our blog on the website
about that. And then there's other tests that you can do. You know, we used to have the IVG test,
but that's back in, you know, in R&D, again, the Navarro test. CIR blog, there's the blog heading
for the Navarro test. The Navarro HCG test measures he would corionic, go to add a trope in your urine.
And it's been a very accurate test for us over the years. We've had a lot of people do it,
and it's very accurate. The other nice thing, it's very inexpensive. The negative thing,
it takes about three weeks to get your results back right now. So, that's another test to know,
how do I know if I'm getting better? You could use the Navarro test. Again, going through that,
how do I know if I'm getting better? Best ways to compare apples to apples, CT, MRI, and Petscan,
and I can spend another hour talking about that these aren't perfect either. Even though these are
gold standard, they are not perfect. We've had cancer patients that did a CT scan, and oh my gosh,
it looks worse, but the patient symptoms are way better. Many times as a cancer is dying,
it's breaking up, and the space-occupied lesion looks larger on a CT MRI scan, and it's not true.
So, it's not necessarily perfectly accurate. So, even though any of these tests, these are considered
gold standard, they're not always accurate. So, just know that also. So, sometimes one of the best
things you could do as far as how do I know if I'm getting better is how are your symptoms? How are you
feeling? That's one of the best ways to know. If you don't have any symptoms, then it's more important
to rely on objective testing, but if you have subjective data, meaning symptoms, that's probably
one of the best ways to know whether a course of care is working for you or not, no matter what anybody
else tells you. So, if you have level 5 paid, and now you're at level 2 paid, you're going to the
right direction. So, not to say that some pain can be good when you're killing cancer, but
just overall general pain.